i sometimes enjoy seeing these social
media posts where people get into the
ice bath they'll look really stoic like
they're really tough
um but actually that's the wimpy way to
go through it
when you get into cold water if you stay
very still you develop a thermal
sheath around you
that you're warming yourself
the the really bold way is to get in and
continue to sift your arms and legs and
it ends up feeling miserably colder
and there's no sheath because you're
breaking up something they're bringing
up that thermal layer and then when you
get out you'll notice a lot of people
huddle or they'll they'll put or they'll
grab the towel in general that's me i'll
get back i'll get into the sauna
but if you really want to stimulate the
big increases in metabolism you stand
out there and you dry off with arms
extended
in open air and as that water evaporates
off you it is really cold but your body
is forced to activate a number of the
warming programs related to metabolism
this is the beautiful work of a woman
named susannah soberg who's scandinavian
she published this paper last year in
cell reports medicine and so i call this
the soberg principle which is if you're
doing ice and heat for whatever reason
doesn't matter if you end on heat or
cold but if you're using cold
specifically to stimulate an increase in
metabolism end with cold that's the
sobering principle
and with cold yeah if you're alternating
and then
if you want to do the tough way you let
the shivering so you just stand out and
let the water evaporate yeah i mean if
you ever waded into a cold ocean you
know everybody's kind of like holding
themselves you know if you really just
if you let yourself extend your limbs
and move them around a bit so you break
up that thermal layer uh that's that's
the tough way to do it so when i see
people on social media getting in and
they're like really tough and trying to
look hard yeah you want to be moving
around yeah
smiling talking moving around is way way
colder yeah
you